but on the other hand we've always been
very conscious in in philosophy of
science of the fact that you know if you
look at the development of modern
science from the time of the Scientific
Revolution onwards then it has
frequently been characterized by
overconfidence and by utter conviction
that we had the fundamentals of the sign
of the the fundamental worldview was
correct and that our fundamental
theories were right
um and not very long later those ideas
were were overturned so hello and
welcome to the cheeky science show where
in this video I spoke with Samir okasha
professor of philosophy of science at
the University of Bristol
smear has made many notable
contributions to the field and
philosophy of biology including a
comprehensive account of the levels of
selection which has widely been accepted
by philosophers and biologists
here we dig deeper into what philosophy
of biology are trying to achieve and the
ways that Samir has contributed to it I
hope you enjoy our conversation very
much so I thought I just sort of jumped
straight into some of the big questions
and actually just ask
why exactly do we need to have
philosophy in terms of thinking about
biology and I think maybe from a more
naive perspective what is actually in
like a simple term meant by philosophy
what's meant by philosophy is a big
question
um but I think a more attractable
question is what we do in philosophy of
biology and why there is the need for
such a field at all so philosophy of
biology is a sub-discipline of the
broader Enterprise called philosophy of
science
um that the most general definition of
which I suppose is that we study
philosophical conceptual and
methodological questions in science
um so philosophy of biology came into
its own in the 1970s
um
when a number of a number of researchers
came to the realization that traditional
philosophy of science was too
physics-centric
uh so while purporting to give a very
general analysis of what the scientific
method is how science Works how
scientific reasoning Works how
scientific concepts are formed and so on
um it is in reality taken all of its
cues from physics and indeed from from
theoretical physics generally
um and so many people started to ask
questions of the form well what becomes
a philosophy of science if we instead
look to the biosciences
and that was the original in part of the
original impetus for the
um for this new sub-discipline the
philosophy of biology I think the
questions that we discuss in philosophy
of biology fall I think into two broad
camps
um on the one hand there are questions
that are sort of internal to biology and
which concern sort of cons
um problematic or conceptually
interesting aspects of the science so to
give you a well-known example
that means frequently been observed that
in the biosciences
much use is made of functional language
so we talk about the function of a
particular organismic trait or phenotype
we ask what some molecular Pathways for
for example we use locutions like in
order to
um
so we we might ask for example
um you know what the function of the
peacock's long tail is for example
and now if you ask an analogous question
in the in physical sciences that would
seem extremely odd and if someone was to
ask you what the function of a mountain
or a glacier is the question wouldn't
really have make any sense at all so
that's long prompted this uh this
philosophical question I mean what's
different about biology I mean why do we
use this this strange language
um in in the biosciences but not in in
in any other Sciences what should we
make of that I mean that's a sort of
paradigmatic example of the the type of
philosophical questions that are
internal to biology the other sort of of
questions that we discuss in philosophy
of biology
um concern the bearing of
biological findings on traditional
concerns of philosophy so a good example
here would be the problem of free will
an ancient philosophical problem that
tries to understand how on Earth it's
possible to reconcile our powerful
belief that we humans have the freedom
to make choices and decisions with the
the facts presuming it is one of
determinism in the natural world other
than perhaps in the in the quantum
Physical Realm we tend to think that the
world operates according to
deterministic largely deterministic
principles of the state of the universe
at any one time we think determines its
state at a later time
um so how is so that's a very old
question in in philosophy and the way
that the biosciences might bear on that
is by looking into the neurobiology of
decision making for example both in
humans and in in other species and
seeing whether we find any anything that
can help us understand the phenomenon of
free will or whether indeed there is
such a thing or it's or whether it's
simply an illusion
so those are examples of the two sorts
of inquiry that we pursue in philosophy
of biology
I mean would you say that it would
curiosity that got you into the fields
in the first place because I know a
couple of friends who like me did like
sort of biochemical like foam molecular
biology backgrounds have like since
transitions I'm just like curious to
know like how you managed to get
yourself into the fields
oh it's by a very non-linear and um
unusual route I guess but I mean that's
true of a lot of people in philosophy of
science so many many people come into
philosophy of science who you know are
very keen on and interested in science
but always end up more interested in the
sort of questions that very often the
lecturers when they're undergraduates
will say well look that's interesting
but just leave that aside because we we
don't really know the answer to that we
don't want to spend our time discussing
that and we want to do the hard science
um so my own initial interests were in
economics and philosophy which was what
I studied as an undergraduate and then
after that I became interested in logic
and philosophy of language in
in my postgraduate studies and then in
in the field of epistemology and from
epistemology I became interested in
questions about the scientific method uh
the reliability of the scientific method
and how best we should understand it and
that then led me into philosophy of
science generally
um for a long time philosophy of biology
was really just a sort of hobby of mine
rather than my main thing
um but this when I was doing my PhD this
was in in Oxford in the in the 1990s
um evolutionary biology in particular
was was very much in the air at the
moment I mean it was the Heyday of
Richard Dawkins and Bill Hamilton
um so there was enormous interest among
among many people in in evolutionary
matters and I became a bit caught up in
that but only later came came to think I
could um bring together my interests in
in evolution with my interests in
philosophy of science and the obvious
way to do that was to move into this
then burgeoning field of philosophy of
biology so that's how I came into it
I see so you mentioned methodology then
obviously I know like my sort of
day-to-day how I go about designing
experiments and conducting experiments
getting data and um my sort of
approaches but what sort of um does your
sort of day-to-day look like as being a
philosopher of biology
oh what does my day-to-day work look
like uh well I mean it's desk bound work
so it basically involves reading books
and articles and studying
um personal study
um collaboration and writing so really
really not so different from any
um
you know academic be it a scientist or
all humanist who's not an
experimentalist if you like
okay yeah I see so um what are some of
the current biggest challenges in the
space or philosophy of biology
oh it's difficult to say
um
let me think some of the biggest current
challenges in in philosophy of biology
well there's been enormous discussion
recently about a notion that people call
biological individuality
which is what I would call a sort of
metaphysical question in biology that
asks what counts as an individual thing
um in in in in biology and to sort of
try and flesh that out a bit
um I mean very often when what we mean
by an individual in in biology as an
individual organism and in certain
discussions then individual and the term
individual and the term organism are
used more or less synonymously we might
say you know consider a population of
ten thousand individuals or something
what do we mean there well we mean
organisms
um but then of course the the notion of
organism is not as clear-cut as one
might think
um so there are very many examples of
things of entities in biology where
we're not really sure whether it should
count as one one individual or Manatee
so if you think of a bacterial biofilm
for example I mean in some ways that's
that seems to be behave like a group of
individuals but then in other respects
it seems to function as a cohesive whole
in itself or if you think of a honeybee
called for example the idea that a
honeybee colony is a counts as a super
organism has a long and and um
controversial history in ecology and an
evolutionary biology but it's still very
very much a live option
um
other people have
tried to sort of problematize the notion
of individual organism by making the
observation that if you include all of
the
um the microbes that inhabit a typical
multi-celled organisms such as a human
then you know you come to the conclusion
that the majority of the cells in in a
human being are not in fact human cells
at all but a but a bacteria
um and have have questioned what we can
in the light of that what it really
means to talk about an individual
organism at all what way we should draw
the boundaries around an organism should
we think of say that um
the gut microbiome of of a human being
as as part of that human or or not
um so those are those that's an example
of some of the questions that go broadly
under the rubric of the problem of
biological individuality people call it
which is it I mean I should say has a
has a long
um and venerable tradition I mean people
have been thinking about this in in
biology you know since since the 19th
century at least
um there was literature on it in the
early early 20th century early to mid
20th century a famous book by Julian
Huxley
um on the notion of biological
individual
um but it's I mean recently philosophers
have taken a particularly Keen interest
in this
so that's one example of a contemporary
um a contemporary issue another issue
that is is not really a new one but is
um never really gone away and has seen a
Resurgence of Interest again is the
question of teleology or goal
directedness so this ties in with the
the brief comments I made about the use
of functional language in biosciences a
moment ago so teleology refers to goal
directedness
um
now it it's temp it's very tempting to
say that there's a lot of goal
directedness in in in biological systems
I mean obviously whole organisms appear
to behave in a goal-directed fashion
um you know as one of migrating bird for
example uh flies South
during the winter months or when a
salmon returns to its natal stream I
mean clearly it's trying to achieve
something its behaviors are not just
random they're directed towards some
some end and you would never really
understand what the salmon was doing
unless you knew what the goal of Its
Behavior was so those seem to be
unambiguous cases of goal-directedness
or apparent goal directedness in the
biological World
um but you find them in many other
places too not concerned with whole
organism Behavior so for example in
ontogeny then it is very clear that
um
as I goed in the process of developing
into an adult organism is undergoing a
sort of goal-directed process if you
like that will reliably produce the
adult organismic form despite lots of
possible
um environmental perturbations and as
long as they're not too too great
um so then this has then led to an
age-old discussion within biology and
within philosophy dating back to
Aristotle about how we should understand
this goal directedness how we should
pick out the goal towards which an
organismic activity or behavior or
sub-process
um appears to be directed and more
generally how we can reconcile this
strong sense that we have that there is
goal directedness in the living world
with our commitment to the study of
mechanism
to understanding all biological
phenomena in a mechanistic way ideally
by understanding their molecular basis a
form of understanding that appears to to
leave little room for the notion of the
goal towards towards which something is
is directed and it's just a matter of
finding out the the causal mechanisms
that underlie the phenomenon of Interest
so that's uh that that general question
of the the the space
um for teleology in the in the in the
the biosciences is I I think um as I say
not a new question but one that's seen a
Resurgence of interest in recent years
among philosophers of Science and of
biology
and so like how have ideas in General
changed over time I mean to go back to
the levels of selection which I know has
been a major interest of your own
um how because this often there's a lot
of discussion about group selection and
then that changed the consulation and
like um how has these Concepts changed
over time and are continuing to change
as we think more deeply about these
different levels of selection
of levels of selectionism is an age-old
controversy within within evolutionary
biology and
um it seems to be one that
you know every generation of
evolutionary biologists seem to feel the
need to kind of reinvent and to
ReDiscover rather and
um
and has led to yeah a a long and
controversial debate that still goes on
today which in some ways is quite
surprising because on the face of it the
issue sounds like it should be a
relatively straightforward one and can
be set up as follows I mean think of how
the basic pattern of argument that
Darwin gave in the Origin of Species I
mean he argued that you know if we had a
population of organisms
um and if they vary with respect to some
of their phenotypic traits
and if some of the phenotypic variants
enjoyed
slight advantage or conferred a slight
advantage on organisms relative to other
alternative traits and if the traits
were heritable or sufficiently irritable
or passed on from parental Offspring
then over time we would get evolutionary
changes that the fittest traits
um proliferated and the poorer variance
died off so I mean that that very simple
description of how evolution by natural
selection works that was in in essence
Darwin's in his Essence in essence still
our understanding of it today boiled
down to its fundamentals treats the
individual organism as what you might
call the the level of selection or some
would say the unit of selection that's
to say it's the differential survival
and reproduction of individual organisms
the fact that some individual organisms
do better than others
um that leads to the evolutionary change
now the levels of selection question
arises from the observation that in
principle biological entities other than
individual organisms such as for example
groups of organisms
um it could be the could be the the
units in uh in an evolutionary process
of the soul that Darwin described so
that's to say we could imagine a process
of group level selection in which it's
not the differential survival and
reproduction of individual organisms
that drives the process but the
differential success of different groups
it drives the process and Darwin indeed
hinted at this possibility and in both
once in the Origin of Species and also
in his book The Descent of Man where he
was concerned with the origin of
pro-social behaviors in early hominids
and Darwin made the um the observation
that within any one group
than a pro-social
um hominid would not who was for example
willing to sacrifice themselves for the
common good and would not leave any
Offspring to inherit his Noble nature as
Darwin put it so would suffer a fitness
disadvantage but he then made the
observation that if you considered
Groupon group competition then it was
possible to envisage a scenario where
tribes containing many individuals who
did look out for the common good Who
were altruistically or pro-socially
inclined might be six might do better
than tribes containing purely selfish
individuals and through a mechanism
therefore of group level selection it's
possible that the pro-social or
altruistic traits could spread and
prosper so that was the first sight of
the first invocation of the idea of
group level selection in in evolution by
Darwin himself and as I say on the face
of it it sounds like it should be a
simple an empirical question
I mean given that in principle natural
selection can operate on entities other
than individual organisms and levels of
the biological hierarchy are other than
that of the individual organism surely
it's just a matter of finding out
whether in fact that has happened or not
maybe it'll be difficult to find out but
it doesn't seem that
the status of that question should be
any different from that of any other
difficult to answer scientific question
however for for a number of reasons the
the question is bound up with is less
straightforward than it seems and is
it involves the kind of mix of
conceptual and empirical considerations
which I think is why it's been
um an issue that is interested many
philosophers of science including myself
and also explains why it is that
biologists can't seem to resolve the
matter and the question seems to
reappear in slightly different guises uh
generation after generation in evolution
of biology no exactly and I think I mean
perhaps I'm wrong but as part of the
explanation for that reason the fact
that there's the levels themselves had
to be a fold as in like like a way back
when life originated it was just
whatever that's that nucleic acid was
and then there was a sort of the
selection level of an individual or at
the cellular level or at a species level
and themselves had to evolve over time
as well and is that it was do you agree
with that
I do agree with that and that's that's
in in fact being a focus um in in my own
work so
um
I mean one way to capture that point is
the following there is a formulation of
the levels of selection question
um for example that given by Richard
lewinton in a famous 1970 paper of his
called uh in the units of selection
where
he he proceeds as follows I mean he says
well look it's just a fact that the
biological world is hierarchically
structured
you know we find
James
making up chromosomes residing in cells
um and cells making up multi-celled
organisms
and then organisms making up you know
larger King groups and groups of other
sorts too and then groups themselves
making up
um you know meta populations or then
perhaps all the way up to species and
all the way up to claims perhaps no so
how I mean how exactly you describe the
levels in that hierarchy is is open to
question but I mean it seems it seems
clear that the biological world is
indeed hierarchically organized so
starting from that premise and from the
point that I made a moment ago that in
principle an actual the process of
natural selection could operate at many
hierarchical levels
um lewinson and many of his many other
people who've set the issue up in in the
same way have posed this general
question at which of those levels does
natural selection operate and that that
formulation is all very well however it
largely takes for granted the existence
of hierarchical organization in the
biological world in the first place and
as you say I mean that's something that
ideally we want to explain and that the
earliest life forms on Earth clearly
were not hierarchically complex but must
have been simple you know
self-replicating molecules of some sort
or
um or other and from there the the
enormous complexity
um later arose so I mean clearly it
can't be ultimately satisfactory to just
take the existence of hierarchical
organization for granted ideally we want
to understand how it is that smaller
units came to form larger Aggregates in
the first place
um a related consideration is this I
mean the response of some evolutionists
to the early debates about group
selection
and what it was just it was roughly as
follows so
a lot a lot of people argued as follows
they said well look it's a theoretical
possibility we grant you that natural
selection could select between groups so
operate at the group level rather than
the individual level
but in practice it's unlikely to be a
particularly important evolutionary
forms
um I mean partly because the generation
time of groups has gone to typically be
much longer than that of of individuals
so you would expect individual selection
to dominate so look the the attitude
then of a lot of people to the some of
the early debates in the 1960s and 70s
was to say well group selection yeah
maybe
um theoretical possibility but not one
we're really going to bother with too
much because we've got good reason to
think that it it um is not a not a
powerful evolutionary Force
however when you reflect on the fact
that the entities we call individuals
you know typically say multi-celled
organisms
themselves constitute groups from a
certain perspective so multi-celled
organism can be thought of as an
extremely tightly integrated cohesive
group of sounds
and obviously as we know that
multicellularity is not the ancestral
condition
um it's evolved you know many many times
over
um but ultimately if we go back 600
million years or or however long ago
then we don't find multi-celled
organisms we find single-celled
organisms so when you make that you know
observation which of course is is well
known then you begin to realize that
this this attitude towards the the group
selection notion couldn't really be
defensible because the I mean the
attitude was to say well group selection
unlikely to be important individual
selection is really what counts but of
course when you realize that an
individual from a certain expanded
perspective temporary expanded temporal
perspective itself constitutes a group
you realize that it can't possibly be
right to dismiss out of hand the the
possibility of group selection because
presumably a process of group selection
is responsible for the very evolution of
the things that we call individuals and
contrast with groups today that's to say
the process by which multi-celled
organisms evolve from single-celled
ancestors presumably must have been a
process that at least in part involve
group level selection involves selection
between you know Aggregates of cells
and favoring ones that
[Music]
um
work particularly well or out competed
single-celled
um single single celled organisms that
hadn't aggregated into these larger
units
so that's another reason why I think
your observation is correct that
we need to understand the origins of
hierarchical organization of group
structure if you like using group in the
most generic sense just I mean group of
smaller units rather than just taking it
for granted
um because I mean to some extent does
that not just mean because of this like
um lack of consensus over wire
selections acting does that not mean
selection in theory could be acting at
each level all at the same time
simultaneously and I mean kind of sort
of similar to that I I think part of
like maybe my naivety is is having these
levels of selection a useful Concepts or
because of there's no clear consensus is
it actually confusing for in terms of
like the applications of of these
nations
and I mean so to take your first
question first yeah I mean I think the
idea that natural selection could
operate at more than one level
simultaneously
um is certainly true and that's that
idea indeed has a name that goes under
the name multi-level selection
um that is an idea with quite quite wide
wide currency
um in in evolutionary biology
and an example of that for example might
be
um
you know if you think of the process by
which a trans person
um spreads through through a population
um by inserting itself in in multiple
locations
um in in the genome so
that is that may sometimes be opposed by
selection of the whole organism level
you know if having too many trans
persons decreases organismic Fitness for
example then
um the the overall evolutionary Dynamics
will be
affected both by you know selection at
the lower level which favors
a favors trans persons that insert
themselves in multiple locations and
um countervailing selection at the
higher level if there's a fitness cost
um on the whole the whole organism
from having too many uh too many of
those so-called selfish genetic elements
within it so that general idea that
selection could out could operate at uh
more than one level simultaneously
certainly true I think
um you then you then ask the question of
whether the
the Notions the whole notion of levels
of selection is too confusing or
something is that right yeah whether or
not is actually being useful in terms of
um being a framework for researchers to
apply or like to to associate with or
whether it's just uh being more help
like is it more confusing than helpful I
think it's kind of where I was going
with it
yeah I mean put it this way I think I
think that a lot of confusion has has
been generated
um
and that's indeed why I wrote a book
about this in in 2006 where I was really
you know I like other philosophers of
science have done the same thing was
just trying to sort of bring some
conceptual Clarity
um to to to the arena
um just by trying to really analyze
different
um different Notions of levels of
selection and study the relation between
different ways of modeling them
um that have been proposed and to really
just try and bring conceptual clarity
um which I think is is ultimately the
task of philosophy both in in the in in
philosophy of biology and philosophy
much more generally and we think of that
as our sort of job in philosophies to to
bring conceptual Clarity where there
isn't any uh so I certainly share your
sense that this is a highly confused
area
um
and in part because of terminological
confusions but I don't think it's just
it's merely terminological in that I
mean certainly you've got cases where
people are talking past each other so
for example some people have used the
expression group selection in a way that
makes it contrast with kin selection but
other people have used it in a way that
makes skin selection a special sort of
it so in some cases just agreement on
what terms mean
is enough but I think in this case there
are more there's a more fundamental
conceptual disagreement about really how
we should understand the process of
natural selection in the first place how
we should think about hierarchical
organization
what sorts of evolutionary explanations
we should be looking for when we're
trying to understand things like the
origin of the the biological hierarchy
so I don't think it's as simple as
saying
you know can't we just all agree on the
definition of the key terms and then the
problem will go away I think the problem
the conceptual
um difficulties are more deep-seated so
I share your sense there's a lot of
confusion I don't really agree that we
can do without these Concepts at all
because I think the general issue
you know arises again and again
um in in diverse areas of biology so so
now you see for example not
you know over the last couple of decades
that a lot of um researchers applying
um
Concepts from social evolution theories
such as kin selection multi-level
selection group selection to microbes
um an interesting interesting and Rich
development
um given that those Concepts were
originally intended to apply to sort of
whole organism social behavior
and now are being applied on you know to
understand social interactions among
bacteria
um
and I think that shows you that the you
know these issues about altruism about
the tension between individual
self-interest and group welfare
um and about levels of selection really
are our perennial ones that will arise
in in almost any
um area of evolutionary biology and so
um
although we may um sort of bemoan the
enormous confusion that still attends
the the notion of levels of selection I
don't think we can do without it
completely
yeah no I think they're really good
points and you've already alluded to
something that I wanted to go to next
which is like the reason that I'm
interested in this is like how can I use
these Concepts in my own like uh
research
um and so I'm very interested at the
moment and understanding like cell
Fitness so thinking at the level of uh
sales selection and how individual cells
might compete in particular because
these theories have already been applied
to understanding the evolution of cancer
development how a cell with a mutation
grows faster and it can out-compete
neighboring cells but also more
generally the opposite where the cell
gets isn't um it's like you can then
apply like the terms like altruism
um spitefulness cooperation in terms of
thinking about cells even though maybe
that's not the right way to be thinking
about it or like I mean I think in a
more general question how would you
think as the sort of biologist or
biologist we should be applying these
thoughts to like um cell based research
interesting yeah um
well let me start by talking about the
first thing you mentioned so that was
the idea that
um we can apply some of these Concepts
about levels of selection and so on to
cancer
um
I mean so that's certainly true that
many people have done that uh so the the
the idea would roughly go as follows so
what you see
um in in cancer is a is a process by
which
um
you know Rogue cancerous cells because
they've accumulated sufficiently many
mutations
um
start to if you like act in their own
self-interest so engage in unlimited
proliferation and ignore topic
topic signals and so um
you know pursue their own
goal of dividing as fast as possible
um to the to the ultimate detriment of
their organism so there it seems as if
we do indeed have a two level selection
scenario we've got
competing cells within the multi-celled
Aggregates
um where the where the nasty selfish
cancer cells just look out for
themselves and abandon somatic function
and solely engage in in unlimited
proliferation
um
where is the normal somatic cells are
the good ones The Cooperative ones that
do what they're meant to be doing
um and the ultimate outcome of that is
that usually
um the the sadly the organism dies so
so then we have
two levels if you like cells within
organisms and the organism level itself
however there is an argument that's been
made that says look
to use the language of social Evolution
so to think of cells as cheating
um or a selfish and as undermining the
good of the whole
is in a way misleading because it
encouraged us to it encourages us to
assimilate the phenomenon of cancer to
other examples of
um
individual group
a conflict of interest in evolution
um you know such as the like the example
I mentioned before of a selfish genetic
element
um proliferating despite harming the
organisms in which it it lives I mean
the fundamental difference in that case
is that
um
the the
in the latter case the the selfish
genetic element case then
um
it can be part I mean it doesn't die the
the
when the organism dies if you like so
the point in other words being that
cancer is non-transmissable apart from
it a couple of extremely rare cases and
so
um
you know for that reason
you might wonder whether it's really
right to think of this as a social
Evolution type problem
um
I mean so I mean if you were dealing
with a transmissible cancer matters
would be very different
because then
yeah I mean you know clearly the
um
and what's the best way to put it
I mean the overall
the overall incidence of the
um the the the mutant
Gene that we're interested in say does
that say there's some
um oncogene that you know causes causes
cancer or something who's whose favor
interest in would then in the case of a
transmissible cancer be affected by
um selective Dynamics at two levels you
know one within organisms but then
secondly also between organisms because
it can lead from one organism to another
if it's horizontally transmitted
um but you know given that given that
cancer almost almost always isn't
transmissible
[Music]
then
some some authors have argued that it's
fundamentally wrong to think of
um the overall
phenomenon here in terms of two level
selection Dynamics
another consideration I think relevant
here is that
I mean you might say look it is
um
why do we think that the spread of
the of
um
of cancer cells within an organism is
really a selective phenomenon at all
I mean is it just because cancerous
cells spread faster than normal somatic
cells
well
I mean
I mean imagine an organism that doesn't
have cancer then clearly somatic cell
division rates vary widely among cell
types and tissues but we don't think of
that as a form of evolutionary
competition you know you don't think oh
those fast dividing skin cells are out
competing they're slowly dividing or
non-dividing neurons for example and
they'll clearly be a bizarre and weird
conceptualization so it can't just be
differences in cell division rates that
make us think that we're dealing with a
selective phenomenon at all here
um so at this point I think it's worth
thinking about the the so-called somatic
Evolution model of cancer that's been
around for for a long long time ever
since the 1970s
um I think is associated with
um mole I think in the
from from the 1970s
which argues that tumorogenesis does
involve a sort of darwinian process as
um
fitter or faster dividing cancer cells
you can gauge in in clonal growth and
out reproduce a slow dividing ones but I
think the key point and that framework
is has certainly proven its worth
and um and I think very very few
um cancer cancer biologists would would
dispute that you really do have an
evolutionary phenomenon there you know
as new accumulations increase and then
there's a selective sweep and then we
get
um we get an evolutionary process
unfolding
um you know within the within the tumor
if you like and that precisely is why
acquired resistance to chemotherapy is
so common
um
and so you can then think of some of the
Hallmarks of cancer as sort of
adaptations that cancer cells have
evolved by natural selection so that's
the sort of basis of the somatic
Evolution Theory but I think the key
thing to realize there is when that
theory is being applied the different
we're talking about differences in
Fitness between cancer cells you know
within a neoplasm right not between
cancerous cells and somatic cells and
some other unaffected parts of the of
the body
so
um
that's why I say I think it's somewhat
misleading to think to talk as if it's
mere differences in in cell division
rates that
um license the idea that we're dealing
with a form of selective competition
does that make sense yeah no I think so
so I mean this is also how I was thought
about like um I guess their useful
principles for us to understand how
Cancer's um can develop over time but
it's not a true sense of thinking about
these different levels of selection in
terms of being able to pass it on to
subsequent Generations so it's is that
kind of the right idea
finally or uncontroversially valid
application of evolutionary ideas
to carcinogenesis
consists basically in the observation
that
um
an evolutionary process does take place
within a neoplasm whereby
New Mutants arise that confer on
cancerous cells the the ability to
divide faster and to escape apoptosis
better
um
and
you know do the other things
such as you know co-opting
um co-opting host issues to supply them
blood and that sort of thing
that enable those cancer cells to to do
better than other ones and so then over
time
an evolutionary process within a
multi-celled organism afflicted by
cancer does unfold
in in in which the
um the the cancer
the feta cancer cells do better than the
less fit ones that I think is certainly
right what I think is more controversial
and more problematic is to think that we
have
a sort of two level selective Dynamics
here in which we have a multi-level
process taking place where the lower
level is the cell level and the higher
level is the organism level
and that's precisely because that
conceptualization would only really make
sense if
um cancer cells if cancer was
transmissible
okay yeah no I see you and actually but
under every since I brought up cancels I
know you recently wrote about it but
interestingly in your commentary you
discussed how understanding cancer may
also help us to understand how
multicellularity arose and I was
wondering if you could comment on that
yeah I mean so this is an idea that so
far as I understand is
controversial in the cancer biology
Community but it's a hypothesis
um associated with Paul Davies and
Charlie line Weaver called the the
atavistic
um theory of cancer and in essence what
those authors are proposing is that
um you can think of
cancer cells rather than being
just sort of Novel phenotypes as being
a cell reverting to a single-celled
lifestyle if you like
where they just engaged in unlimited
proliferation and so their idea is that
you don't have to think of cancer cell
as having an entirely novel phenotype
but rather as having acquired mutations
that
enable it to revert to
um
the lifestyle of a single celled
ancestor of all the of all the the
metazoa
um
which I think is I mean is a fascinating
idea if it's true and I think this means
some evidence such as that
I believe in in many cancers genes that
are of non-metazone origin are up
regulated
um which is you know possible evidence
in favor of this idea that the the
behavior of
um a modern
a cancer cell is
somehow akin to the behavior of a
single-celled organism
way way back before the before the
origins of
um before the evolution of
multicellularity in first place
um so I mean I'm not qualified to
comment on the sort of empirical
plausibility of that idea although I I
do believe that it's it's quite
controversial
um my interest in it stem from the idea
from the thought that I mean if that was
true then that would give you a kind of
genuine rationale for thinking of
um cancer in terms of the concepts of
multi-level selection and social
Evolution precisely the thing that I was
claiming was problematic a moment ago on
account of cancers non-transmissibility
and so I was arguing that if something
like that atavistic theory of cancer is
true the theory that modern cancer cells
have reverted to
um the lifestyle of the seeing their
single-celled ancestors then that would
give you a rationale for thinking of
modern cancer cells as selfishly
um as behaving selfishly in much the
sense of the term selfish in which it's
standardly applied in Social Evolution
Theory
yeah that's a good point um and so in
addition to like how these Concepts in
philosophy of biology are helping like
us molecular biologists understand what
we observe does it go both ways are like
how are new discoveries being made and
like what components are in a cellulite
besides DNA like non-genetic information
how is that new advances influencing the
concepts in the philosophy of biology
um yes it's a good question I mean I
wouldn't really say that philosophy
biology necessarily helps anyone in
molecular biology
um I mean it would be nice to think that
you know we philosophy of science
generally could sometimes be of
practical benefit
um to to the the working scientists but
and some some of my colleagues in
philosophy of biology and philosophy of
science are very keen on that idea
um that what we're doing in reflecting
philosophically on science is something
that's of direct practical benefit to
the the the the working scientists
um I've always thought that to be
slightly over optimistic and not really
to be
the right yard stick against which to
evaluate philosophy of science in that
that's not really the aim of the the
Enterprise if you like I mean the aim is
really more conceptual and theoretical
than that and it's
he is trying to make sense of stuff
and
trying to aspiring for a kind of
conceptual Clarity that
is is very appealing for people of some
of a certain intellectual orientation
but and if that turns out to be
practically useful wonderful but I don't
necessarily think it that that's its
goal
um but the other half of your question
was well what what's the relevance of
the findings of molecular biology for
for philosophy of biology well
um I I think they that they are many
um
I mean so for a long time then people
working in in philosophy of biology
tended to focus on evolution
um and that certainly is my own my own
interest is largely in in questions and
evolutionary theory and other questions
about how evolutionary ideas bear on
traditional philosophical debates
um
but some time ago a number of
philosophers of biology started to argue
and I think they had a point that this
near exclusive focus on Evolution was
was anomalous and didn't
um necessarily make much sense because
there were fascinating philosophical
questions arising in molecular biology
too and one example of such a question
is the notion of
um genetic information
and how we should understand that and
why we should use why the informational
language should be used in in molecular
biology and and didn't in molecular
developmental biology as well
um
you know given that ultimately
you know molecular biology is a highly
reductionistic mechanistic science and
it's about how you know working out how
how stuff works at a fundamental
biochemical and and molecular level and
you might wonder
why there's any role for Concepts
Concepts such as information or
information transfer
um or developmental program
um in a science with it with such an
overtly mechanistic orientation and then
this gave rise to
um an interesting body of body of Works
in in the philosophy of biology uh
partly prompted by some some ideas of
the evolutionist John Maynard Smith who
drew attention to this problem and led
to
um some interesting suggestions about
how the notion of genetic information
should be understood another area where
molecular biology has influenced the way
that philosophers of biology thinkers is
of course in the field of epigenetics
and particularly
um the the the the recent discoveries
surrounding epigenetic inheritance
um
and so a lot of people I mean not just
in philosophy but also in in diverse
areas of biology and and related fields
have started to wander
you know how best we should understand
Notions such as inheritance
um transmission and heritability you
know key Notions in evolutionary biology
in the light of all of the reasons
um the flurry of attention
paid to to epigenetics
so I do think there's um yeah I mean I
do think that despite molecular biology
being a sort of
um notoriously sort of
experimental not a not theoretical
branch of of biology
um I do think that it's replete with
implications that are in fact
philosophically interesting
that's a really good point and I think
kind of on from that
um perhaps there is no like right answer
to this but would we ever know when you
get to a point where you have the right
answer
um or like in terms of philosophy
science it's more like um having the
best explanation
um or the best Concepts that explain
what's currently known
um I don't think I've explained this
very well but is that like there is no
definitive endpoints I like to go back
to the levels of selection how would we
ever know that we have the right
Concepts in place or is that even the
right question to be asking
I think you're right so philosophical
questions by their very nature don't
really have final answers in the what
we're trying to
do in philosophy is really ask a very
abstract general question of the form
you know what's the right way to think
about something
and there isn't generally a final answer
to that and that's why philosophical
debates you know to the frustration of
some people both within and without and
outside the discipline never really seem
to get resolved but that's not to say
that progress isn't made in philosophy
it's just not relevantly similar to
Scientific progress I think is the right
thing to say even in a branch of
philosophy such as the philosophy of
science where we you know make a great
effort to integrate our philosophical
reflections with with the findings of of
modern science
um and in the case of some researchers
with History of Science so
um despite that I still think that
philos the questions we ask in
philosophy of science are more akin to
traditional philosophical questions than
they are to Scientific questions invert
they're not the sort of question that
really have final answers or final
resolutions well that's not to say that
you can't answer them do better and
worse in your attempts to answer them
and you can't make make
increasingly sophisticated attempts to
answer them as we think we have done in
philosophy of science over a sort of
hundred year period
yeah no for sure and I think one way
that I see it is is that it's been
useful when giving the fields more
clarity over these Concepts and I think
kind of on from that I was just
interested to know how you've failed
like to what extent philosophy of
biology helps to add trust to like
science and scientific methods in terms
of like communicating
um to the public about uh like more
recent things that have happened like
the the covert pandemic and just um
being a sort of like mediator between
basic science and communicating it to
the public
yeah I mean some philosophers of science
do see that as a role
um as a potential role for the subject
um
what to say about that
well
I mean I think certainly the the the the
the the pandemic the Covenant pandemic
did drive home the importance of science
good science communication and
put issues such as trust in science and
and Trust in scientific expertise right
to the Forefront of the of the public
discussion
um Can philosophy of science contribute
to that
I think so
I mean one reason for that is that
and this is speaking really more about
philosophy of science than philosophy of
biology I mean a key concern in
philosophy of science has always been
how we should reconcile
um our strong belief that you know
science is the the best way of finding
out about the world and even though it's
not perfect and you
scientific mistakes happen and
scientists don't always get it right
that clearly the rational thing to do
for very many in most circumstances is
to defer to what scientific experts are
saying be it about covid and virology
and epidemiology or or about climate
change or about you know the safety of
self-driving cars or or about you know
what whether a new drug is effective
or whatever I mean what better way of
forming your opinions about the world is
the than to defer to the science so on
the one hand there's that sort of
pro-scientific attitude that most people
in philosophy of science share with the
scientific community
but on the other hand we've always been
very conscious in in philosophy of
science of the fact that you know if you
look at the development of modern
science from the time of the Scientific
Revolution onwards then it has
frequently been characterized by
overconfidence and by utter conviction
that we had the fundamentals of the sign
of the the fundamental worldview was
correct and that our fundamental
theories were right
um and not very long later those ideas
were were overturned
um so that sort of humility that an
acquaintance with the history of science
forces us to have about the scientific
Enterprise is a bit difficult to square
with the enormous success of modern
science and the great confidence that we
all feel we should have and the
deference we should pay to Scientific
experts and trying to sort of navigate a
sensible course between those two poles
recognition that the history of science
is a history of error and often
characterized by overconfidence
with the fact that science seems like
the the best way of
finding out about the world
um has long been a central concern of
the philosophy of philosophy of science
um so I think for that reason philosophy
of science is is well placed to engage
in this discussion about scientific
expertise and about trust in science and
to help combat some of the
um
the anti the anti-scientific sentiments
in in in some quarters
yeah I see however I should say again
that I mean I think of that
I mean it would be great if philosophy
of science could do that
but as with my previous comments about
the Practical benefit or philosophy of
science for the working scientists I
don't think that's the right yardstick
to evaluate it by if you like and that
that's not the that's not the primary
goal
of the philosophy of science but it
would be wonderful if it could make a
contribution in that regard
despite it not being its primary goal
okay in that case then what I mean what
to you is the primary goal I don't know
if you've already touched the planets
but like just to make it super clear to
the listeners
yeah I mean I think of of all of
philosophy
um
including the philosophy of science
as a you know ultimately trying to
achieve deeper understanding
um
and a deep and a type of understanding
that is complementary to the
understanding that science provides us
um but is distinct from it in its
integrative conceptual
dimension in the sort of we're just
interested in really big picture stuff
often in in in in in philosophy and
we're attracted to questions that
um
you know many many other academics find
interesting but ultimately too abstract
to spend your whole life working on
um
so if you think of a classic
philosophical question such as you know
what is knowledge what do we mean by
knowledge what is it what do we mean
when we say that someone knows something
now I I mean I I could quickly run
through some examples to convince you
that there is a real issue there it's
not as simple as it seems
um
and I think most people would be
persuaded by those examples that that
there is a real question here about what
knowledge is
um
um but I think to not many people would
want to spend their the whole academic
career researching that question because
people do in philosophy I mean that's a
central question in the field of
epistemology
um so that's just the point I'm making
here is that the questions that attract
Us in philosophy that we think are
important are extremely abstract
questions and that remains true I think
even of the branches of philosophy like
philosophy of science and philosophy of
biology that aspire to have a close
integration with
um modern science
so
that is for those reasons that I'm
cautious about this idea that philosophy
of science is definitely of practical
benefit I think it's definitely of
intellectual benefit and I think it will
be wonderful if more science students
were exposed to some philosophy of
science would that make their day-to-day
lab-based science better that I'm not
sure of would it make them into more
rounded intellectuals definitely yeah no
I can agree with that
um so in terms of your own research what
is like next on the horizon for you in
terms of both your research and I guess
also other books or anything else that's
going on
um sorry what was the last bit um or any
sort of books or any other projects that
you're working on
yeah no so at the moment I'm working on
a book called understanding Fitness that
is about the concept of Fitness in
evolutionary biology
um it's I think there was one author who
said that who said of that concept that
everyone knows what Fitness is but no
one can define it
um and somewhat surprisingly for such a
a foundational Central Concept in in
evolutionary theory there are there's
long been debates and I would say indeed
on clarity about what exactly the
concept is doing what the role of that
concept is how we should understand it
um about how you should measure it
mathematically about
a number of philosophical questions
surrounding this concept the
philosophers of biology of long being
troubled by uh particularly in regards
to questions about probability
um so what I'm trying to do is to
produce a sort of synthetic overview of
the debates surrounding the concept of
fitness with a trying to reconcile
um what seems to me or trying to resolve
what seems to me a puzzle which is on
the one hand
we all believe that we understand the
process of evolution by natural
selection and the theory of it extremely
well and that the idea of differential
Fitness that some
um phenotypes or traits are fitter than
others is that right at the very heart
of that theory and yet despite that
there seemed to be all of these
different accounts of what that concept
really is understandings of what the
role of the Fitness Concept is
disagreements about the right
mathematical measure of Fitness in
different circumstances and
philosophical disagreements about what
Fitness is all about
um and what I'm trying to say is well
how could that be if we all understand
very well the basic the basic
evolutionary theory so that's the that
will be the subject of my book
understanding Fitness that I hope to
have finished in a few years
oh great no I I mean like I said uh
earlier I can have the cellular Fitness
this is something myself I'm like
naturally interested in so I really look
forward to that
um and speaking of books I can see like
part of a bookshelf in in your room at
the moment do you have any sort of books
uh that you think have been really
um like memorable like very like made
you really uh change the way you thought
about things or just any general good
book recommendations
oh well that's quite a brawl question
um any general book recommendations in
what sort of area are you thinking of
anything I mean entirely up to you I
mean sometimes people ask me for book
recommendations and I don't always
recommend a Biology book but I think my
audience is very diverse so
um anything that yeah you thought was
um really made you think
um
let me think
well I'm drawing a blank here sorry it's
uh
yeah I think I I just read too many
books to be able to answer that easily
sorry that's okay well I can definitely
recommend
um your philosophy of policy book um for
my fears because I definitely found that
really as a useful primer to understand
the main Concepts in the fields so yeah
I highly recommend you checking out
um that book
um and in terms of that where can I
direct my viewers if they're interested
to learn more about your research
oh about my research
um well to my web page
um
or to that of my
current ERC project called representing
Evolution that touches on many of the
themes we've talked about
um but I think to my web page at the
University of Bristol would be the
immediate place also the book you held
up the the one called philosophy of
biology a very short introduction or to
another book I've done in the same
series called philosophy of science a
very short introduction those are two
books in the the Oxford University press
series very short introductions many of
which I think are useful in both both
science and in philosophy
great yeah and I'm for sure I can do
that
um so yeah best of luck with writing
your book and your future research and
just thank you again for coming on today
it's been a really interesting
conversation
okay thank you very much
bye for now so I hope you've learned
something in this video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening